bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette édition de fin de semaine de votre
journal d'information locale le tour de
l'actualité du jour mais aussi retour
sur les principales informations de la
semaine comme chaque vendredi voici
quelques-uns des sujets que nous allons
développer au cours de la prochaine demi
heure à leur âge venu vient de tenir son
dernier conseil municipal à la verrière
beaucoup d'émotion alors que l'élu
communiste annonce son départ pour des
raisons de santé
nelly duthu lui succède officiellement
la nouvelle réunion publique à guillon
cours pour évoquer la réalisation de la
ligne 18 du métro du grand paris les
discussions restent mouvementée et du
côté de l'essentiel de la semaine les
déplacements d'emmanuel coste ministre
du logement à la verrière et de manuel
valls premier ministre à mantes-la-jolie
retour aussi sur la réouverture du
donjon de houdan et la rénovation de
clairefontaine avant l'ouverture de
l'euro 2016
dans l'actualité du jour tout d'abord la
cgt qui appelait ce vendredi matin à la
mobilisation à versailles contre je cite
la politique osterrieth air du conseil
départemental du département des
yvelines
le syndicat s'oppose notamment la fusion
des services archéologiques des yvelines
et des hauts-de-seine et qui sera à
marquer à part des suppressions de
postes une fusion qui fait suite au
rapprochement annoncé des deux
départements dont les présidents veulent
faire des économies
la ligne 18 et ces controverses lundi
dernier nous avions fait part des
inquiétudes des riverains du quartier de
la bretonnière à voisins le bretonneux
concernant le tracé de cette ligne qui
devait passer sous leurs habitations
et hier soir une réunion publique a été
organisée à guyancourt au pavillon
waldeck-rousseau l'objectif toujours
informer et recueillir les remarques des
habitants concernés directement ou
indirectement par le tracé de cette
ligne 18 camille lambert et fanny
bourdillon pour les précisions relier
versailles chantiers à l'aéroport d'orly
en 30 minutes c'est le défi que tentent
de relever la ligne 18 lancée par la
société du grand paris en 2011
le projet fait actuellement l'objet
d'une enquête publique depuis le 21 mars
2016 jeudi 14 avril dans le cadre de
cette enquête
une réunion publique était organisée à
guyancourt pour recueillir les remarques
des habitants
c'est un exercice de démocratie
participative
ce n'est pas la société du grand paris
qui organise ses rayons public c'est la
commission denquête ce n'est pour n'est
plus dans le cadre la concertation est
donc le but c'est que le public puisse
exprimer donc on laisse un large temps
si vous voulez aux questions réponses et
il ne faisons qu à observer les
questions réponses et ensuite dans notre
rapport nous analyserons ces questions
réponses la commission denquête a déjà
recueilli plus de 2000 courriel une
cinquantaine de permanence sont
installées dans les mairies des villes
concernées inquiétude principale le
financement des travaux
la profondeur du tunnel et les
conséquences écologiques
je suis venu aujourd'hui cette réunion
parce que bien sûr le métro le tracé
initial on va dire j'espère qu'il va
bien changé passe effectivement très
proche de ma maison dans le monde de la
rénovation deux de nos transports sur le
rer b pour mettre un tramway et enfin il
ya tout un tas de solutions qu'on pas
été étudiée qui répondraient beaucoup
plus aux besoins de la population et ses
cinq ans que nous demandons les
habitants ont encore jusqu'au 26 avril
pour faire part de leur inquiétude à la
commission denquête après analyse des
différentes problématiques elle émettra
son avis favorable ou défavorable
la décision finale reviendra au
gouvernement la mise en service de la
ligne 18 est prévu pour 2024
tout juste quatre ans après avoir
succédé à pierce élincourt à ce poste
alain à jaja donc quitter son fauteuil
de maire de la verrière hier soir jeudi
un départ en raison de sérieux problèmes
de santé nous l'avons rencontrée juste
avant que ne se déroule ce dernier
conseil municipal
écoutez son interview je réalise pas
bien je vais te prends un coup je ne
réalise pas bien que ces derniers
conseils que ces dernières journées de
mandat même si on s'y prépare forcément
donc côté je vais bien je vais faire que
je fais d'habitude
on gérera la situation et en essayant de
gérer les émotions qui vont avec parce
que c'est forcément un moment difficile
je prend du repos donc on va on va
commencer par ça et puis si la ville a
besoin de moi si la personne qui sera
élu du tueur l'occurrence sans doute a
besoin de moi je me rends très
disponible dans la mesure de mes moyens
mais bien sûr qu'il ya des projets
beaucoup de choses qui me tiennent à
coeur j'ai lancé beaucoup beaucoup de
choses sur cette ville donc j'aimerais
bien voir où tous ces projets vont
aboutir
j'ai pas le sentiment qu un maire doit
forcément inauguré ou aller jusqu'au
bout des projets je trouve que la plus
belle place et quand même d'initier de
lancer de proposer de créer les
conditions de la réussite donc de ce
point de vue là je trouve que en quatre
ans le bilan est plutôt intéressant bien
sûr il ya des choses qui ont bien
fonctionné d'autres moins bien mais mais
voilà ça ça me dérange pas de ne pas
être là le jour où les choses se finisse
ou les projets sa chaise c'est normal
c'est le rythme de la vie c'est comme
vous êtes maire c'est tous les jours
tous les jours des petites choses et il
ya plein de la limite c'est une grande
satisfaction c'est quand vous arrivez à
trouver une solution à quelqu'un qui en
détresse ça franchement c'est des
moments qui me touche fort quand une
personne reste en détresse vient vous
voir n'a pas de solution d'hébergement
et vous allez vraie vie dans les jours
qui se fient voulu trouver une solution
franchement c'est du bonheur c'est du
bonheur quelqu'un qui revient vous voir
et vous dis tiens vous m'aviez orientées
sur des emplois et puis j'ai réussi à
trouver une piste comme un levier
conseiller ça marche c'est du bonheur ça
c'est voilà moi je suis plus attaché à
ces petits bonheurs là que sont
finalement les possibilités qui sont
donnés à chacun de trouver des réponses
à des situations de crise ou des espoirs
ça ça me marque profondément honnêtement
c'est les relations qu'ont avec les gens
quand on est maire s'est beaucoup ça
avec la population avec les partenaires
avec ce qu'ils vivent et travaillent sur
le territoire et avec l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux économiques
politiques
ça c'est vraiment riche de l'expérience
de rencontre ont des fois des déceptions
ci mais aussi quand même beaucoup de
plaisir donc à ce plaisir là premiers
kills celui d'être au contact avec les
gens et de pouvoir faire avancer le
deuxième c'est globalement je pense sans
orgueil aucun c'est ce que je pense que
la verrière est un peu en mouvement
alors on entend parler de la verrière on
est sans doute ça c'est une fierté que
faire pour moi être fier de sa ville
c'est important et donc que les verriers
roi soient fiers de leur ville que le
libéria roi sentent que leur ville est
capable d'inventer et d'innover de créer
de se développer de répondre par le même
à des besoins
pour moi ça c'est la grande fierté il ya
peut-être deux choses qui m'ont qui
m'ont marqué un peu pendant ces années
je suis pas mais lui depuis 21 ans donc
quatre ans mère mes 21 ans de mandat
c'est l'évolution un peu de notre
système politique du rapport au monde
politique du rapport au pouvoir du
rapport du citoyen au pouvoir ça je
trouve que mon niveau en 21 ans je l' ai
vu évolué et aujourd'hui le
désenchantement la désespérance le
manque de confiance dans les élus ne
rend pas toujours facile l'exercice du
mandat
et comme en plus par ailleurs on nous
prive de moyens on ne donne plus de
responsabilités moins de compétences et
moins d'argent
honnêtement aujourd'hui est maire cette
terrible c'est terrible c'est usant
épuisant on passe plus de temps à
trouver de l'argent des moyens à
combattre pour les intérêts de sa ville
qu'à mettre en oeuvre son propre projet
c'est et je crains que les années
passant il est de moins en moins de
candidats pour être mère parce que c'est
vraiment pas un parcours de santé c'est
le cas de le dire
et puis la deuxième chose c'est ce
rapport un peu compliqué au monde
politique - me sens un peu différent
c'est moi qui le dis je suis pas un
homme de parti je suis pas un homme
d'appareil j'aime ce que je fais comme
mr j'aime ce que je fais comme citoyen
je suis engagée depuis très longtemps
depuis je suis très jeune et donc je
trouve qu'il ya un entre soi dans le
monde politique qui me dérange
profondément et que ce soit dans tous
les partis
et c'est il faut vraiment que quelque
chose bouge de ce point de vue là c'est
pas acceptable
l'éloignement entre les citoyens et les
hommes politiques est considérable il ya
beaucoup d'hommes politiques qui ne sont
plus dans le monde réel
moi j'ai un espoir après si je leur
dirai de ce soir d'ailleurs c'est
vraiment que les les gens prennent leur
destin en main il n'y a pas d'autres
solutions il faut vraiment de grands
coups pire la fourmilière elle a besoin
d'être secoué cette fourmilière cc s'est
passé pas c'est pas normal d'avoir
autant d'injustices autant de
discrimination autant de pauvreté dans
nos villes enfin derrière on est bien
placé pour le savoir
et en même temps être confronté à une
telle richesse qu'on il suffit d'ouvrir
les écrans et d'écouter la radio et
entendre tout ce qu'on a c'est pas
possible c'est humainement pas possible
et après on cherche à comprendre
pourquoi il ya des problèmes de violence
des crises et autres
oui mais sont menées peut-être de notre
propre manière de conduire les affaires
et la société ne pas répondre aux
préoccupations des plus importantes pour
les gens quoi est ce décalage là il est
normand me leur envoie en tant que maire
tout le temps tout le temps tous les
jours pourquoi c'est si difficile de
trouver un boulot pourquoi c'est si
difficile d'avoir un logement pourquoi
on n'est pas respectée pourquoi on n'est
pas entendu ça c'est quelque chose qui
était prégnant en tout cas pour moi
et j'ai essayé en tout cas je pense
qu'un maire il est là aussi pour donner
d'espérance et le d'espoir car sinon
qu'ils sont au quotidien près des
habitants on n'affirme pas gai de
l'espoir qui va le faire qui va se faire
donc voilà ça c'est la constante un peu
du message qu'on doit avoir et je vous
propose d'écouter à présent la réaction
de michel laugier le président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines également maire de montigny le
bretonneux divers droite il a longtemps
travaillé avec alain ajaj dégage
quelques et que je parte je pas les
velléités politiques mais avec qui j'ai
toujours su travailler en bonne
intelligence dont c'est quelqu'un que je
respecte en tant que maire et en tant
que homme aussi donc c'est vrai que je
suis triste de ce départ surtout dans
ces conditions là donc je les souhaite
tout simplement un prompt rétablissement
et j'espère avoir le plaisir de le
revoir
conseillère municipale également
conseillère communautaire de saint
quentin en yvelines nelly du tu deviens
donc la nouvelle maire de la verrière à
58 ans professeur des écoles elle est
aussi membre du parti communiste
français a comme alain ajaj et elle veut
faire de la jeunesse la priorité de ce
mandat
le départ d'alain ça nous a quand même
tous un peu
marquez quoi après voilà le fait d'être
mère c'est aussi une grande émotion une
grande responsabilité mais aussi une
grande détermination à poursuivre le
projet le prochain week-end c'est quand
même un projet qui nous tient à coeur
tous autant qu'on est au conseil
municipal
et puis ce que j'ai dit dans mon
discours un le social et les jeunes ça
c'est ma préoccupation c'est mes
priorités et nous reviendrons lundi sur
ce dernier conseil municipal avec
notamment les réactions de l'opposition
sur la verrière économie à présent hier
soir jeudi 14 avril au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines avait lieu la
première rencontre de la communauté open
innove lancé à l'automne dernier par la
cci de versailles yvelines
une soirée pour renforcer le maillage
des membres de ce réseau et valoriser
les porteurs des projets innovants
sephora namani mélanie poker bienvenue à
la première app innove
jeudi 14 avril au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines avait lieu la
première rencontre pour la communauté
open your love un échange intéressant
aussi bien pour les startups tels que ce
cas log que les grands comptes comme
renault ça permet effectivement d'être
d'être plus compétitif de se rendre
compte de la réalité du terrain de
d'avoir accès à un certain nombre
d'outils des gens qui ont l'agilité la
flexibilité et la réactivité face à des
idées qu'il développe et on n'est pas à
l'abri de trouver la pépite sur laquelle
on pourra s'impliquer créer une
dynamique d'ouverture dans l'innovation
c'est le défi du réseau open innove
lancé à l'automne 2015 par la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de versailles
yvelines en partenariat avec les groupes
rono kpmg fidèles et banque populaire
un réseau qui compte déjà plus de 200
membres ce réseau au pays d'oz
son objectif c'est de créer une
communauté de l'innovation dans les
yvelines de mettre toutes les structures
et tous les acteurs de l'innovation
ensemble et qu'ils puissent échanger
donc c'est déjà une plateforme numérique
mais c'est aussi des rencontres comme
organisées sur tout le territoire des
yvelines et c'est la première
effectivement à saint quentin en
yvelines après une heure de débat les
130 entreprises présentes pour cette
première app innove ont pu profiter
d'une séance de networking pour
découvrir les start up et pme innovantes
du territoire et bin-houin éducation ce
matin à l'iut de vélizy les étudiants de
l'école d'ingénieurs is tille ont
organisé un concours particulier un
concours d'éloquence neuf candidats ont
participé ils ont débattu sur des thèmes
imposés
doit-on boire ou subir la pression
peut-on chercher midi à quatorze heures
chaque étudiant avait dix minutes pour
convaincre l'assemblée dans
l'amphithéâtre une centaine d'étudiants
mais aussi un jury composé de sept
professionnels de la communication
n'écoute les participants à ce concours
au micro de fanny bordier l'objectif est
double il ya un premier objectif qui est
de s'amuser parce qu'on entre étudiants
et un deuxième objectif qui est de se
perfectionner dans le domaine de la
communication qui nous sera utile dans
notre futur métier d'ingénieur
j'ai pris le sujet le moment est il un
frisbee pour ceux qui n'ont pas d'amis
alors au début j'avais une toute autre
approche mais j'ai choisi de faire les
relations humaines
donc entre les hommes et les femmes est
aussi l'amitié
j'ai choisi comme sujet le père noël est
il une ordure justement la difficulté
majeure c'est d'écrire le texte puisque
la communication ça s'apprend par contre
l'écriture de textes un peu plus
compliqué c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
de nombreux candidats mans abandonné
c'est parce qu'ils ont une réelle
difficulté à écrire un texte
d'autant plus qu'on est dans un cadre
étudiants donc on a envie de faire rire
nos copains copines du coup c'est
compliqué de trouver des phrases qui
fasse rire vraiment un amphithéâtre
europe
et comme chaque vendredi nous passons
maintenant à l'essentiel de l'actualité
le zapping des principaux sujets que
nous avons développée depuis lundi dans
ce journal bailleurs sociaux acteurs
immobiliers et conseillers municipaux de
la verrière
ils étaient tous réunis autour de la
ministre du logement emmanuelle cosse et
lui ont présenté les projets
d'habitation de la commune il faut qu'on
rapproche l'activité économique les
logements parce qu'on sait que
typiquement notamment pour les habitants
des yvelines
beaucoup d'entre eux travaillent sur la
région le centre de paris ou à la
défense et qu'on a des temps de
transport extrêmement difficile depuis
monte la jolie et le premier ministre
est venu annoncer les priorités
2016-2017 du plan de lutte contre la
pauvreté et pour l'inclusion sociale on
retiendra la nouvelle hausse du rsa + 2
% en septembre pour la quatrième année
consécutive la ligne 18 qui devrait
relier orly et versailles chantiers
d'ici 2030 ne fait pas que des heureux
des habitants de voisins-le-bretonneux
sont inquiets du tracé actuel du métro
automatique
elle devrait passer sous leur habitation
dont le sol est déjà fragilisée le
principe c'est tout simple c'est à
partir d'une goutte de sang au bout du
doigt 30 micro lite donc une toute
petite quantité de sambre et ben qu'on
va déposer sur ce test est au bout de 15
minutes
la personne aura le résultat de son test
de dépistage de l'hépatite c
un test disponible à partir du mois de
mai pour les professionnels et les
associations entre 2500 et 3000 porcs
sont abattus chaque semaine dans ses
locaux situés à houdan l'abattoir
guillard ans est le dernier
établissement de ce type en
ile-de-france depuis 2013 les normes
européennes du bien-être animal ont été
renforcées vincent hareng directeur de
l'abattoir yvelinois s'assure du respect
de ces règles
nous mettons les ports par deux dans des
ascenseurs et des cendres dans une
concentration à 90 % de co2 qui les
endort immédiatement c'est une aventure
dans laquelle il fallait réunir la fois
des financements se charge très lourde
pour d'autres
et puis ne pas se tromper de projet à la
fois faire une réhabilitation
archéologiques mais qui soit compatible
avec des usages modernes visites
touristiques contes concerts etc
inaugurée pour les joueurs c'est qu'ils
viennent s'entraîner il faut qu'ils
aient d'une qualité terrain aussi bonne
que dans les grands clubs et des joueurs
de haut niveau donc aujourd'hui l'effort
à café sur tous les terrains ils ont un
gazon l'afld exceptionnel qualitatif
donc ça c'est important au niveau
médical on est bien d'équité au niveau
technique de récupération on n'est pas
fait de les équiper
on recherche 150 étudiants pour cet été
pour rendre des visites de convivialité
nos personnes âgées isolées sur tout le
département donc concrètement on a lancé
une grande campagne de candidature et il
faut se rendre dans les coordinations
gérontologiques de chaque territoire
et puis on pose un cv aux candidates
et puis si on est retenu on passe une
petite journée de formation et ensuite
on est envoyé pendant tout l'été sur le
terrain depuis je fais top chef
matschiner a évolué parce que j'essaie
de donner plus mon identité à moi parce
que derrière les revend j'étais vraiment
dr simonet maintenant j'essaie vraiment
de me donner mon style de cuisine est un
peu plus
créatif on va dire j'ai pris plus de
confiance en moi par rapport aux
services à leurs rapports avec l'équipe
il est de plus en plus fort c'est vrai
que je suis je suis plus en plus
passionné par mon métier
et puis on retiendra également dans
l'actualité la tenue prochaine d'une
nouvelle élection pour désigner
président et vice président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines le tribunal administratif a
décidé d'annuler le précédent scrutin du
9 janvier dernier expliquant que les
conditions d'accès au public n'avait pas
été respecté à la majorité de saint
quentin en yvelines ne fera pas appel
elle évoque des polémiques politiciennes
elle souhaite un apaisement
alors tout ce beau monde a décidé de ne
pas faire appel par rapport aux yeux des
magistrats dit même si je la conteste et
même si aujourd'hui les éléments de mes
avocats nous donner toutes les raisons
de pouvoir gagner en conseil d'état
simplement ça va encore faire six mois
de retard et on court beaucoup d'argent
dépensé pour moi cette nouvelle élection
est un non-événement donc je
représenterai exactement les mêmes
délibération que j'avais présenté au
mois de janvier on c'est à dire que
toutes les communes de gauche seront
représentés dont le bureau d'art
continuera pas de délégation offerte à
la gauche et après ce résumé de la
semaine retour de notre séquence regard
de jeunes sur l'actualité comment les
plus jeunes perçoivent l'information
locale et nationale
l'extraction des animaux c'est la
disparition des espèces animales dans le
monde il ya beaucoup d'espèces animales
qui disparaissent très vite il ya une
espèce animale ou végétale
elle disparaît tous les 20 minutes on
sait très bien que la planète elle est
déjà fortement pollués on pourrait les
protéger en n'ayant plus de gardes
forestiers qui est surveille pas que les
braconniers pour protéger les animaux
parce que on a quand même besoin
je veux dire il ya toujours la loi de la
nature la chaîne alimentaire pas oublié
si un animal qui disparaît c'est lui qui
est il manche et bailly va se multiplier
encore plus on peut l'aimer temps des
dans des centres ou alors au moins pour
les protéger pour voir si ce format de
santé parce que ils peuvent ne pas être
en bonne santé
si on on laisse les gens de tuer des
animaux ils vont me pousse 10 paraphé un
jour rien ne rend presque plus passera
que par exemple évoque les moutons et
les autres ceux qui sont unanimes au
soir et seront ils sont morts du coup
bah c'est pas bien quoi les foi peut
qu'en l'espèce et disparaissez pour un
peu c'est à cause de la pollution tout
ça du coup faudrait plus faire des
voitures électriques 20 qui polluent moi
tout ça apparemment il ya six espèces
d'ours sur huit qui sont menacés je lis
les protégés pas les laisser comme ça
parce que ils peuvent plus disparaître
plus facilement il ya des espèces qui
sont importantes pour la biodiversité
aussi que des espèces de tigres baril
augmente pas c'est plutôt bien
c'est une très bonne nouvelle parce que
moi j'allais en a déjà éliminé assez de
l'espèce donc si on a une qui se
repeuple c'est une très bonne très bonne
au m
on va présenter des sujets que nous
développons à partir de lundi sur cette
antenne les assises de la ruralité
voulue par le département des yvelines
compte-rendu présenté vendredi soir ce
soir lors d'un rendez-vous publics à la
ferme du manet à montigny le bretonneux
et des mesures d'accompagnement dead
sont attendus par les agriculteurs mais
aussi les habitants des communes les
plus excentrés et puis également le
point sur l'action de rsf le réseau
éducation sans frontières qui depuis dix
ans dans les yvelines prend en charge
les jeunes cherchant à obtenir un titre
de séjour pour poursuivre leurs études
un rassemblement est prévu notamment à
versailles ce week-end nous y
reviendrons dans un instant les idées
sorties loisirs pour les prochains jours
avec le 7-8 week end préparé par mélanie
poquet et peut-être allez-vous vous
lancer durant ce week-end dans le tricot
le tricot qui n'a plus rien de démodé il
connaît même un nouvel engouement en
france
les tricots café qui sont nés aux états
unis se multiplient dans l'hexagone il
ya même dorénavant une journée mondiale
du tricot à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est une mort païenne qui a décidé de
partager sa passion regard des
débardeurs ponchos pull ou encore des
sacs on peut tout faire soi même et en
tricot une motivation pour quatre lignes
santis de banc qui a ouvert en septembre
dernier sa propre boutique
j'aime beaucoup tricoter déjà de base
c'est après et en toute petite part mon
arrière grand mère et je me suis remise
à tricoter vraiment quand je suis tombée
enceinte pour ses côtés pour mon bébé
comme beaucoup de jeunes mamans et donc
j'étais en licenciement économique à ce
moment là j'avais déjà l'idée de créer
une société enfin j'avais toujours envie
de travailler à mon compte et en fait je
me suis dit pourquoi pas ouvrir une
boutique de laine vendre des pelote
donner des conseils mais aussi animer
des ateliers le tricot ce n'est pas
seulement le gros pulls en laine divers
il ya aussi les fils d'épée avec du
coton il n'y a pas de la haine du coup
on n'en parle pas beaucoup on parle
souvent de la laine mais on ne fait pas
mais on peut aussi tricoter pour les
paie donc chaque composition est
différente chaque couleur est différente
et chaque texture aussi est différent
tomates hélène qui sont bien tissé et
puis d'autres qui sont un peu plus
fantaisie à l'image des tricots café
venu des états unis
kathleen senti cette banque propose
aussi des ateliers où se mêlent
apprentissage et convivialité
vous avez la façon de
montés ils étaient collés que tu auras
plat que je ne connaissais pas pour moi
même à mon âge c'est une découverte il
ya des personnes qui ont commencé avant
moi qui s'y connaissent et je peux
apprendre beaucoup d'eux preuve que le
tricot encore de beaux jours devant lui
la journée mondiale qui lui est
consacrée aura lieu le 11 juin 2016 à
vos aiguilles édition vous avez encore
le temps de vous exercer à la pratique
du tricot c'est la fin de cette édition
du journal replay sur notre site
internet ainsi que pour toutes les
émissions et les reportages de la chaîne
je vous retrouve lundi aux horaires
habituels très bon week-end
vous